son los ex alumnos del colegio de la
salle somos un colegio de iglesia donde
a nosotros nos formaron diciendo que
había que hacer algo por los demás que
había que ser solidarios
que había que transformar las cosas
y nosotros vivíamos en una burbuja
nos vivíamos dándonos cuenta de lo que
sucedía en nuestra sociedad en nuestro
país estando muy cerca de nuestro
colegio
y empezamos a hacer trabajos empezamos a
salir con la pastoral empezamos a ir a
distintos lugares y empezamos a conocer
realidades muy distintas a la nos a la
de nosotros
siendo personas iguales que nosotros
pero la formación la formación cristiana
la formación católica la formación de
nuestra familia que siempre fue un poco
vertical
el bueno ayuda al malo el rico ayuda al
pobre y es a esa cosa vertical
a nosotros en un principio nos llenaba
de egocentrismo en qué sentido en el
sentido que hoy qué lindo lo que hacen
qué bonito qué linda experiencia qué
buenos son
y claro uno que eso
y cuando cree eso está lejos de lo que
los demás necesitan y de lo que a los
demás les va pasando como persona
partimos
[Música]
cuando estábamos en la universidad pablo
estaba en la chile
yo estaba en esta universidad y dijimos
qué hacemos con todos los regalos que
tenemos como persona familia como
normales una familia común y corriente
sin grandes lujos
un colegio con buena enseñanza en que
los valores nos recalcaban los valores y
además de esos valores católicos
teníamos a la iglesia que en ese tiempo
ocupaba una encíclica que decía los
pobres no pueden esperar que era la
encíclica de pueblo
y estábamos nosotros yendo todos los
sábados a la población santa julia donde
habían grupos de niños y jóvenes que
vivían algo completamente distinto
volvíamos a nuestra casa
volvíamos a nuestros sueños a la
universidad a hacer deporte a salir con
nuestros amigos con nuestras amigas y la
realidad ha quedado ahí
pasó un año
y seguía muriendo
y seguíamos tratando de que algo
cambiará en la vida de esos niños y
jóvenes que estaban ahí
sin embargo todo lo que hacíamos era
infructuoso
la situación era la misma
los niños no podían ir al médico porque
estaba siempre resfriado siempre
enfermos no iban al colegio
entonces después
paso al segundo año y cuando vimos que
ya nada podía dijimos vamos a vivir con
ello bueno
obviamente que a los 22 años no teníamos
nada
no teníamos nada sea nada material
y lo primero lo primero que hicimos fue
rentar una casa y una casa donde en
huérfanos con esperanza
y donde nos conseguimos la hablada con
los profesores del colegio
cuál era nuestra idea
nuestra idea era decir
podemos hacer algo distinto podemos
cambiar podemos pero necesitamos estar
con ellos
aún
sigan pensando en que todavía es cierto
la capa de superhéroe porque todos te
decían que lindo lo que haces seguía
funcionando de forma efectiva el
egocentrismo la línea entre el
egocentrismo y el amor es muy delgada
qué pasó después
bueno tres meses después que estábamos
viendo con los niños y teníamos que
comer una sopa con cebolla porque no
habíamos calculado que había que comer
todos los días no habíamos calculado que
la casa tenía un baño para 25 personas
no habíamos calculado que la casa no
tenía patio entonces no había dónde ir a
jugar así que íbamos a la quinta normal
a jugar
todavía seguíamos mirando a nosotros con
todos los patrones familiares que
teníamos con todos los patrones de
educación que habíamos recibido
un año después
nos empezamos a dar cuenta
y enviamos a todos los niños un mismo
colegio
ya no todo alto no a todos los niños le
iba bien
algunos leído mal
y nosotros seguíamos insistiendo en que
tenía que irles bien porque la única
forma que nosotros conocíamos era que
tenían que estudiar y salir adelante
y ahí
en ese momento algo pasó pasaron dos
cosas dos cosas importantes
después de un par de años más
uno de los jóvenes que se fue con
nosotros
dijo yo quiero estudiar educación física
quiero ser profesor
cuál fue nuestra primera reacción
nuestra primera reacción fue
que salgan todos de cuarto medio estamos
cumpliendo ya una meta extraordinaria
error
repitió primero medio revivió tercero
medio cien profesor
y eso nosotros nos mostró que nosotros
era los que estaban muy equivocados en
el sentido de que hay cosas que pueden
variar y que es necesario que varían
ya este goce entrismo religioso en el
sentido de decir que tú eres el que vas
a salvar el tú el que ya no existía
éramos todos iguales y teníamos que
construir caminos para cada uno y para
todos
y todos eran niños distintos niños
diferentes de diferentes edades
todos tenían una historia distinta
cuando aprendimos
eso
nos dimos cuenta que habían distintos
colegios que habían distintas soluciones
que habían niños que tenían capacidades
diferentes y que teníamos que empezar a
buscar caminos diferentes para cada uno
cuando logramos entender
eso
realmente muchas cosas cambiaron para
los niños de nuestras casas
muchas cosas cambiaron porque
porque no todos iban a ser profesionales
porque no todos iban a llegar a la
universidad porque algunos tendríamos
que buscar caminos distintos
entonces que dijimos frente a esto que
tenemos que lograr una base valórica
para todos igual
por eso desde un principio partimos con
una cosa pequeña nunca pensamos en que
algo numeroso era la solución nunca
pensamos en que tener 100 niños para dar
de comer y tener un techo era algo
válido sino que siempre pensamos en que
había que ir a las reuniones de
apoderados había que ir a las citaciones
de los profesores había que apoyarlo en
las clases
había que contenerlos
porque hay una situación obviamente que
es mucho más profunda
qué es todo el tema emocional
y todo ese desafío todo eso el ir
dándose cuenta de eso hace que cada uno
cada vez uno se vaya comprometiendo más
y más y vaya fijándose en más detalles y
en más detalles y en más detalles
qué es lo que pasó
paso que muchos niños terminaron el
colegio muchos niños terminaron la
universidad
pero eso es
esta parte
cuál es lo más importante
que el 98% de los niños
y a hombres y mujeres que son papá y
mamá están con sus hijos eso no tiene
en comparación con otras cosas
sabes lo que es para una persona sentir
que puede ser papá puede ser mamá
después de que no ha tenido un modelo
del dolor
el camino que hay para lograr es
gigantesco
y cada persona que logre eso puede
llegar muy lejos
por eso es que esta experiencia no es
una experiencia solo mía es de muchas
personas que han construido esto
ahora vamos a ver tres ejemplos para que
ustedes tengan una idea solamente para
que ustedes se lleven
un mensaje de
si podemos
si podemos construir un lugar una
sociedad un país lugares más justo
mejores para los niños mejores para los
jóvenes no importa en el área que
estemos
no importa de donde lo hagamos no
importa si yo estudio esto estudio lo
otro tengo un oficio
todos podemos ayudar a construir algo
mejor es simplemente decir que yo me
puedo poner en el lugar del otro que yo
puedo sentir lo que le está pasando al
otro que yo puedo ver
que yo puedo estar en el lugar del otro
no de una forma teórica no de una forma
de cifras no de una forma lejana sino
que estar junto a las personas yo creo
que todos en este lugar todos en nuestro
país siempre alguien nos ha ayudado a
veces nosotros nuestro con centrismo y
nuestra esa mirada que queremos
solucionarlo todo nos lleva a pensar que
no hace pero todos tenemos a alguien que
nos ha ayudado todos en algún momento
hemos recibido ayuda de alguna persona
es por eso que siempre en nuestra
sociedad habrá personas que necesitan
una mano de otro y a veces de otro que
uno no conoce
por eso el llamado a servir el llamado
es a entregar lo mejor de nosotros
siempre como persona
voy a contar tres historias pequeñas no
voy a utilizar el dolor ni esas cosas
para porque nunca hemos creído en el
sentido de eso porque todos entendemos
el dolor que siente una persona cuando
está en un lugar que no ha elegido
y esas tres historias relatan un poco
como personas que llegaron a nuestra
casa a nuestro hogar
hoy son papas
su mamá pero se han desarrollado también
universitariamente
ella es la roma con su hijo joaquín y
con su esposo alejandro
la roma llegó a los cuatro años nuestra
casa
y la primera conversación que yo tuve
con ella
ella me dijo que quería ser enfermera
que soñaba con ser enfermera
uno como adulto dice
sí bueno será puede ser a lo mejor
le dice que bueno estudia
pero todo lo que pasó
todos los años que llegaron
todos los años que pasaron se fueron
construyendo de la siguiente manera
nosotros arrendamos una cosa una casa en
santana de chena
que había que caminar como 2 km para
salir a tomar una micro que los llevará
a la estación central y de ahí para
llegar al centro de la ciudad
era lejos
construimos una casa a pulso en trinidad
con la florida donde en ese tiempo no
había nada
justo había un colegio de unas monjas
del colegio divina pastora que nos
dijeron cuando estaba maipú si alguna
vez se cambian a la florida bueno hay
becas
nos cambiamos la florida ocupamos la
beca
que no cupo la beca
aroma
salió del colegio
yo
y quiero la universidad de santiago
en enfermería
se movilizaba hablando de la micro y
estas cosas que se demoran y todo eso
bueno
ir de la florida hasta ya era un buen
trecho
y hoy día ella trabaja en la clínica
dávila en pediatría oncológica
oncológica tratando de servir un poco a
través de lo que ella recibió y a través
de lo que hace
segunda historia
felipe
felipe llegó a los 14 años
vivía en el norte de chile
la primera conversación que la tuvimos
la tuvimos en el comedor de la casa
porque él fue a conversar conmigo para
ver si lo podía ingresar al hogar a
nuestra casa la primera conversación
tienes buenas notas sí tengo buenas
notas
y qué quieres ser que te gustaría cuál
es tu sueño
a mí me gustaría entrar a la escuela de
suboficiales de la aviación
y le dije yo y por qué porque a mí me
encantan los aviones me encanta todo
esto
perfecto
vente a vivir a nuestra casa
y empieza
a reconstruir tu vida porque lo que
quiero decir es que acá detrás de esta
historia no solo está esta parte hay una
parte que ustedes comprenden muy bien de
lo que hay
de lo que hay detrás de la parte social
pero insisto solo tocar la parte escolar
donde ingresó al instituto de la salle
porque claro como nosotros somos
lasallistas los colegios de la salle
tienen que ponerse por supuesto
en todo
brillante
brillante como que como alumno 67
promedio
se ganó en cuarto medio y en tercero a
finales del 0 ustedes saben cómo
funciona el mercado
preuniversitario pedro al día beca
creativa los mejores promedios ahí
estamos con la beca
de la prueba
en toda la ingeniería en aviación
comercial en la santamaría
todo iba bien todo iba perfecto nosotros
jugando a la pelota a las 4 de la tarde
los domingos irresponsablemente cierto
él tenía que estudiar el estado a las 4
de la tarde
estudiando
y nosotros jugando a la pelota
él sabía que estábamos jugando a la
pelota pero él se mantenía firme
estudiando
y la niña que está allá llega al hogar
hacer voluntariado de alemania
vienen por un año al hogar a servir a
descubrir su ocasión a mirar qué es lo
que pasa acá
se enamoran
ella estudia trabajo social viene a ser
practicada chile entre comillas cierto
y qué pasa
felipe empieza a estudiar alemán
bueno bien que termine esta historia
esta historia termina en que felipe
estudia ingeniero espacial en la
universidad de stuttgart
se casan con la vida
y ahora tienen dos niños esos son sus
hijos y viven en alemania y él trabaja
en una empresa sugiere entre una empresa
de aviación
tercera historia
la de más adelante
la sandra
a los 18 años
me voy del hogar no aguanto más las
reglas no quiero estudiar más le va así
en el colegio
se fue a los 18 años no perdimos nunca
el contacto
pasó el tiempo 1920 lo estoy pasando mal
estoy pasando frío estoy pasando hambre
y después de un tiempo debería de ser
quiero estudiar voy a la psv
la app a la que ustedes quieran
se prepara
ya tenía 24 años
a la izquierda en biología marina
en concepción
muy bien
ya la situación estaba
había vuelto a su cauce normal
ya podríamos contactarnos ya podríamos
restablecer ya ella había madurado
algunas cosas nosotros también
nos vamos
primera casa que tiene una casa de
monjita duró poco
ya
la hacían estudiar mucho no sé pero duró
poco después
termino
término biología marina
salió adelante
y hoy día dónde está
hoy día está en australia
ahora está viajando pero están en
australia haciendo un doctorado en
biología marina
entonces
con estas historias no quiero decir que
todos los niños que todas las personas
van a llegar a la universidad y van a
terminar felices la historia porque no
es así
solo quiero decirle
que en muchos casos se puede
y que tenemos la misión tenemos la tarea
tenemos la labor
entre todos de construir un lugar mejor
para nuestros niños para nuestros
jóvenes y será un país mucho más lindo
de vivir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]